SO WE JOIN WE'RE JOINED NOW BY
FORMER JACKSONVILLE
JAGUAR AND
LIKE I SAID, ONE OF THE TOP 40
UNDER 40
TASTEMAKERS NAMED
BY WINE. ENTHUSIASTS. WILL
BLACKMAN. WHAT DO YOU PAIR?
TREVOR
LAWRENCE?
HIS FIRST NFL START WITH, IF
YOU'RE WATCHING THE GAME AT
HOME.
WHAT DO YOU
DO HERE IS START WITH
YEAH,
LISTEN, AS LONG AS LONG AS
URBAN'S, NOT IN THE CABINET
MESSING WITH THE WIND AND YOU
KNOW WHAT, THEN YOU KNOW, I
WOULD PAIR HIM
WITH SOME TACO LOSE WHICH IS
A FAMOUS
TACO SPOT IN JACKSONVILLE.
THEY
ARE THEY ACTIVE LIST. THEY
HAVE A HAMBURGER TACO
CHEESEBURGER, TACO
LEGIT,
SO
TREVOR LAWRENCE GETS HIS.
FIRST NFL, START YOUR
JACKSONVILLE JAGUARS FAN.
YOU'RE SITTING ON THE COUCH.
LET ME GIVE IT. LET ME GET
THIS CHEESEBURGER TACO
TO WATCH THE QUARTERBACK OF
THE FUTURE.
HOW ABOUT
FOR THE FIRST GAME?
ROUTE ITSELF. I THE RAMS
PLAY JUST ABOUT A NINE IRON
AWAY FROM THE
RICH EISEN SHOW STUDIOS WEEK.
1 AGAINST THE BEARS. YOU THINK
IT'S A BIG BODY BAROLO KIND OF
GAME,
BIG BODY, GIRL KIND OF GAME
HERE, YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW.
I'M CURIOUS. IT'S STILL GOING
TO BE WARM. SO YOU DON'T YOU
DON'T WANT ANYTHING BIG BODY.
YOU WANT SOMETHING COOL, YOU
MAYBE A KE
CHABLIS FROM FRANCE. YOU KNOW,
THIS CRISP ACIDIC, IT'S FUN.
THAT'S SO
PHI OR MAYBE ACTUALLY, YOU
KNOW, WHAT BEING THAT. IT'S SO
IT'S SO
SOMETHING FROM STAN. KROENKE.
YOU GOT TO GET WHOLE NADA. YOU
GOT TO GET HIS WINE. SO WE GOT
TO KEEP IT, KEEP IT IN THE
FAMILY.
THE NFL DOESN'T GET AS MUCH
CONVERSATION AROUND WINE
AS THE NBA. DOES. WE'VE
BEEN TALKING AT LENGTH ON THIS
SHOW ABOUT CHOSEN FAMILY FROM
CHANNING FRYE AND KEVIN LOVE.
HOW CJ MCCOLLUM TURNED HIS.
ROOM AT THE NBA BUBBLE
INTO A WINE CELLAR. MAKING
SURE THAT IS 80 BOTTLES OF
PINOT NOIR WERE CHILLED
EXACTLY, RIGHT?
WHO ARE THE BIG WINE GUYS
LEVEL? THE NFL ON A REAL
BECAUSE YOU WERE LIKE I SAID,
THE TOP 40 UNDER 40,
TASTEMAKERS FROM WINE
ENTHUSIAST.
WOULD THINK ABOUT IT THOUGH?
ON THE ROAD, RIGHT? AND YS
THERE'S ONLY
12 TO 15 GUYS, ON THE ROSTER,
YOU CAN HAVE A DINNER.
EVERY TIME YOU'RE ON A ROLL,
BUT 12 OF 15 PEOPLE,
SO, I MEAN, AND THAT'S
THE DOING THE HANGING OUT
WHERE
FORTY THREE GUYS AT A
RESTAURANT, EVERY TIME WE GO
OUT
THAT IT WOULDN'T BE AS AS FUN
AND I FEEL LIKE
TO
BEING THAT IT'S LEBRON.
THAT'S LEADING THE CHARGE
THE BEST PLAYER, YOU KNOW, IN
THE NBA
THEN OBVIOUSLY THAT'S GOING TO
GET A LOT OF ATTENTION,
BUT IN TERMS OF THE NFL, I
MEAN
FIRST OF ALL,
I LIKE TO GIVE A LOT OF CREDIT
TO GUYS LIKE CHARLES WOODSON
AND
ANDREW BUT SO BECAUSE THEY'RE,
THEY'RE MAKING WINE LIKE,
CHARLES HAD IT HAD HIS OWN
WINE SINCE 2005
THROUGH BLOOD. SO ACTUALLY
LIVES ON THE VINEYARD IN
WASHINGTON AND THERE ARE
MAKING WINE. SO I THINK
I GIVE THE SLIGHT EDGE TO
BUT IN TERMS OF CONSUMPTION IS
DEFINITELY THE NBA GUYS. LIKE,
I DON'T THINK WE'RE EVEN
CLOSE,
BUT I KNOW, LIKE, A COUPLE OF
MY CLIENTS IS LIKE,
MATT RYAN WRIGHT. HE WAS MY
TEAMMATE AT BC AND I HELPED
HIM CARRY HIS WINE CELLAR. HE
HAS A HUGE COLLECTION. I KNOW
MATT STAFFORD HAD TWO HUGE
COLLECTION
SIDNEY RICE. HE HAS A HUGE
COLLECTION. SO THERE'S A
THERE'S A COUPLE OF GUYS OUT
THERE BUT NBA BY
FAR, NOT EVEN CLOSE.
WELL, ROCKLAND JOINS THE SHOW
SUPER BOWL CHAMPION AND
SOMMELIER. WE HAD QUENTIN
RICHARDSON ON THE
OTHER DAY. WELL, WHO'S
JESSE THAT
TJ JEFFERSON
BUILD A WINE CELLAR TO
PRESERVE HIS AIR JORDANS
BECAUSE HE NOTICED THAT
THE SOULS WERE FALLING OFF
HIS AIR JORDANS
PRESERVING
WINE, LOT OF RUMORS OUT THERE
THINKING THAT THE OLDER, THE
BETTER
BUT FOR THE
EVERY DAY DRINKER OUT THERE
WHAT ARE A FEW THINGS THEY
NEED TO BE AWARE OF TO
PRESERVE THEIR WINES AT HOME.
SAY, IF THEY WANT TO PAIR IT
WITH
TAMPA BAY, NEW ENGLAND,
WHEN TOM BRADY RETURNS TO
GILLETTE STADIUM.
LISTEN, YOU'RE GONNA BE A BEER
FOR THAT GAME.
THERE'S NO WINE FOR THE CD
BEER AND WHISKEY FOR THIS ONE,
BUT
THE BIGGEST THING IS YOU WANT
TO KEEP IT
OF A SOME MIGHT, YOU KNOW, YOU
DON'T WANT
SOMEWHERE.
MR. THE TEMPERATURE. ALSO,
YOU WANT TO KEEP IT AWAY FROM
LOT OF LIKE
VIBRATION BECAUSE I INTERRUPT.
CAN INTERRUPT THE WINE AS WELL
TOO. AND YOU DO WANT TO STORE
IT ON ITS SIDE BECAUSE THE
IMPORTANT THING IS YOU WANT
THE WIND TO BE IN CONTACT
WITH THE COURT.
SO THAT ACTUALLY STAYS THAT
THE
EXACT SIZE
WHEN IT BECOMES
TO THE COURT BECOMES HARD
AIR CAN GET INTO THE WINE, IT
ACTUALLY EXPEDITE AGENT ALSO
CAN MAKE THE WINE FAULT. SO
YOU DEFINITELY WANT TO STORE
IT PROPERLY
PROPERLY LIKE THAT.
SO YEAH, BUT FOR THAT
PATRIOT BUCCANEERS GAME, IT IS
BEER.  IS HARD LIQUOR AND IT'S
NO WINE WILL BE CONSUMED
THAT DAY.
I THOUGHT BECAUSE IT'S TOM
BRADY, JUST BE SITTING ON THE
COUCH, CHUGGING KOMBUCHA WILL
BLOCK THEM AND JOINS THE SHOW
THEN LIONS IN FOR RICH
AND RICE ON THE
RICH EISEN SHOW
THESE LONDON GAMES HERE ON THE
WEST COAST. THEY START EARLY.
WHAT'S A GOOD BREAKFAST?
WINE?
YOU KNOW WHAT,
WHEN IN DOUBT IT'S CHAMPAGNE
FOR ME. I KNOW
PEOPLE WANT TO SAY MOSES, BUT
IT'S CHAMPAGNE.
THE CHAMPAGNE GOES WITH
ANYTHING
OR YOU CAN JUST CALL IT
SPARKLING WINE
KAABA CREMANT, WHATEVER
IT IS
SPARKLING WINE. HIS WAY TO GO
IN THE MORNING
RAHMAN. DO YOU IMAGINE SITTING
ON THE COUCH ON A SUNDAY
MORNING WITH JACKSONVILLE?
READY TO KICK OFF FROM ACROSS
THE POND AND YOU OPEN A BOTTLE
OF CHAMPAGNE TO START A
THREE-DAY LIKE THREE-GAME
PARLAY THAT THE SUNDAY. IT'S
HAPPENING. I KNOW. ABSOLUTELY.
IT'S HAPPENED LAST YEAR. IT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN THIS YEAR LIKE
GET READY.
AND OUT. THERE. WILL JACK IS
ON, WE HAD A PLAY IN THE CRACK
OF DAWN. IT WAS
I'LL TELL YOU WHAT, THOUGH,
ONE THING ABOUT PLAYING IN
LONDON.
SO I WAS FORTUNATE TO PLAY IN
SUPER BOWL WITH THE GIANTS
THAT WAS
DAMN NEAR THE CLOSEST
EXPERIENCE
TO A SUPER BOWL WAS PLAYING AT
WEMBLEY.
IT WAS ABSOLUTELY
MADNESS.
I MEAN, I THINK I SAW A BUBBY
BRISTER JERSEY IN THE STANDS.
THAT ALL KINDS OF
JERSEYS OUT THERE.
IT WAS SUPER COOL. IT WAS
EXCITING.
WELL, BACK WHEN JOINING THE
SHOW FORMER NFL DEFENSIVE
BACK SUPER BOWL CHAMPION
AND
SO, MOYET, TOP 40 UNDER 40
ONE
TO GIVE SOME PROPS TO PATRICK
MAHOMES. HE'S BRINGING
WHATABURGER TO KANSAS CITY
AND MISSOURI
AS YOU NOW, ENTER THIS NEXT
PHASE IN YOUR CAREER. DO YOU
PAY ATTENTION TO SOME OF THE
INVESTMENTS KAISER MAKING
ESPECIALLY IN THE FOOD AND
BEVERAGE SPACE?
I DO PAY ATTENTION BECAUSE
IT'S FUNNY. WE HAVE ALL THESE
MEETINGS.
FINANCE GUYS
THAT COME IN AND,
YOU KNOW, YOU'RE KIND OF LIKE,
YOU DON'T REALLY THINK AHEAD
IN TERMS OF YOUR FUTURE AND
WHAT YOU SHOULD BE DOING,
AND
I REALLY LOVE THE
FACT THAT RESPECT THAT THE
GUYS ARE MAKING THESE MOVES
NOW. I MEAN, YOU'RE SEEING
YOU
SEE MORE AND MORE ESPECIALLY
WITH THE WHOLE, YOU KNOW,
MORE THAN THE ATHLETE. YOU SEE
ALL THE THINGS THAT LEBRON HAS
DONE, MORE ATHLETES ARE
STARTING TO
BE SMARTER WITH THEIR MONEY
AND
MAKING
WISER DECISIONS.
FOR OBVIOUSLY FUTURE
INVESTMENT. SO
I THINK IT'S COOL. I THINK
IT'S IMPRESSIVE AND I,
I LOVE THE FACT THAT GUYS ARE
STARTING YOUNG AND LEARNING
NOW BECAUSE
ONCE YOU GET THE PARK TO
IT'S DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW, YOU
WANT TO MAKE, YOU WANT TO BE
ABLE TO LEARN HOW TO HAVE
YOUR MONEY, MAKE MONEY. YOU
KNOW, IT'S
ONCE YOU LEARN TO DO THAT
BECAUSE IT'S WAY HARDER
TO KEEP TRYING TO MAKE MONEY.
SO LEARN HOW TO HAVE YOUR
MONEY, MAKE MONEY IF THAT
MAKES SENSE.
WELL, YOU TWEETED OUT
FOR WORDS THAT GOT BROCKMAN
FIRED UP
LIVE TONIGHT.
LET'S GO. WELL,
MAC 10 IS IN THE BUILDING.
LET'S GO.
LISTEN. I'M ACTUALLY IT'S
FUNNY. I BECAME GOOD FRIENDS
WITH DUB. SEE
THE OTHER MEMBER WESTSIDE
CONNECTION.
HIS SON
ACTUALLY IS A REALLY GOOD
HIGH SCHOOL RUNNING BACK
AND
SO IT JUST REMINDED ME OF
THAT. SO I HAD TO THROW IT OUT
THERE. BUT YES MAC-10
HE'S SWITCHING SWITCHING HIS
NUMBER TODAY,
I WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO SEE
HIM IN 50. THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN COOL.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT FROM ON THE
FIELD GROWTH IN? COOL? WHAT DO
YOU EXPECT TO REMAIN ON THE
FIELD? AND
YOU SUGGEST MAYBE LIKE A
GAME. I DON'T KNOW. I SAW THAT
COMBINE BODY. THERE'S NO WINE
THAT BODY. THIS
THIS THE GUARDS AND BUD LIGHT
AND THAT BODY KIND OF POWER.
REAL. BLACK WILL JOIN IT.
WITH THESE WINE. PAIRINGS KNOW
WHAT? I, HERE'S THE THING,
WHAT I WENT TO GREEN BAY.
YES, THAT'S WHERE I REALLY
STARTED TO TAKE INTEREST IN
WINE,
AND IT WAS HUGE BECAUSE
THE TEAM AND HE WAS  ALSO ON
A HUGE.
I WAS A HUGE ONE GUY AND THAT
MADE ME MORE COMFORTABLE DRINK
WINE,
I T
AND I LOVE ME  BEER TOWN
A COLD BEER.
SO WHEN IT COMES TO FIERCE
FOOTBALL AND WINE IS GREAT,
BUT SOMETIMES MAN YOU JUST YOU
JUST GOT TO CRACK OPEN
A MILWAUKEE'S
BEAST. NOT A BEST
BEAST. THESE JOISTS
THESE. YEAH, WE'VE BEEN
REMINISCING HERE AS WE'VE BEEN
CATCHING UP ON SOME OF THE OLD
BEVERAGES OF CHOICE THAT WE
HAD OVER THE YEARS, SOME HAVE
HORRIFIED US FROM OUR PAST.
OTHERS,
OTHERS, HAVE BROUGHT BACK.
MANY A FOND MEMORY
OF MANY A NIGHT FORGOTTEN,
WILL BLACKMAN JOINING THE
SHOW,
THEN LIONS IN FOR RICH ON THE
RICH EISEN SHOW
GETTING INTO THE FOOTBALL OF
IT ALL. ARE YOU ONE OF THOSE
GUYS WHO THIS TIME OF YEAR,
YOU'RE DRIVING AROUND LOOKING
FOR FRIDAY
NIGHT FOOTBALL GAMES. IT JUST
CRY, LIKE ROSS, TUCKER AND
WATCH THE SIT STAR-SPANGLED
BANNER. ARE YOU JUST AWAY FROM
THE GAME? WANT NOTHING TO DO
WITH IT?
NO, I YOU KNOW WHAT? I WAS
JUST GOING TO SAY, I'M NOT
THAT CREEP. THAT JUST WATCHED
ANY FOOTBALL, BUT THEN AGAIN,
MY WIFE
LISTED AND SHE'S PROBABLY NOT.
ON HER HEAD. LIKE YES, YOU ARE
THAT CREEP? THAT JUST WALK
GROSSMONT.
KNOW. I DON'T
HERE'S THE THING. PEOPLE
ALWAYS ASK ME THIS QUESTION.
THEY GO. HEY, LIKE DO YOU MISS
IT? AND I HATE WHEN GUYS LIKE,
OH, NO, I DON'T MISS IT. YOU
KNOW, MAYBE THE CAMARADERIE.
HELL YEAH. I MISS IT. I MISS
IT LIKE CRAZY.
FOOTBALL. IN THE NFL WAS THE G
ONLY THING
I EVER WANTED TO DO.
THAT, WAS IT. I HAD NOTHING
ELSE. I JUST WANTED TO PLAY
FOOTBALL. I'VE BEEN BLESSED TO
PLAY 12 YEARS
AND YOU KNOW,
I'M VERY HAPPY.
WHAT PART TO, YOU KNOW, I
OBVIOUSLY THE MAIN THING TO BE
HOME WITH MY WIFE AND KIDS WAY
MORE.
THAT'S MY MOST IMPORTANT
INVESTMENT,
BUT
I'LL ALWAYS MISS PLAYING CAUSE
THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO DO.
SO, YES,
I'LL WATCH. I'LL WATCH ANY
KIND OF FOOTBALL.
I'M ACTUALLY
HEADED TO HOUSTON BECAUSE I'M
GOING TO BE
AN ANALYST FOR THOSE FLAG
FOOTBALL GAMES.
I'M CALLING GAME FOR FLIGHT
FOOTBALL. I WILL WATCH ANY
FOOTBALL
MAGICALLY TRYING TO
DENY HIM, TRYING TO TAKE OUR
SUN TO GO. WATCH HIS FRIEND.
FRIEND. WHO'S
TEN YEARS OLD PLAY, FOOTBALL
/ HAVE FOOTBALL PRACTICE. SO,
YES, I AM THE
PSYCHOPATH. THAT WATCHES ANY
FOOTBALL.
I'LL SEE A KID. THROWING THE
FOOTBALL. HE'S, HE'LL THROW A
DUCK AND I'LL PULL OVER BLEEP.
THIS IS HOW YOU THROW A
SPIRAL.
AWESOME.
THAT'S AMAZING. THAT'S
AMAZING. YEAH, THE PASSION.
JUST DO ME A COCA-COLA,
THE FASHION FOR THE GAME. YOU
CAN'T, YOU CAN'T TAKE AWAY
FROM YOU GUYS. WILL BLACKMAN
JOINING THE SHOW, BEEN LIONS
SHOW R RICH, THE RICH EYES AND
BE MESSED UP. LIKE, IF
YOUR PROFILE
OKAY, YOU PLAY GOLF. IF YOU
SEE A GOD, YOU'RE WITH
SOMEBODY
AND HE'S JUST LIKE SLICING
THEM.
WHAT DO YOU LIKE? TELL HIM TO
RIGHT? YEAH, THAT WAS FOUR T,
HOURS OF MY LIFE YESTERDAY.
PLAYING WITH CHRIS CROCKER.
SO IF I'M DRIVING IT OVER, I'M
IN A PARK AND I SEE A KID JUST
THROWING DUCKS AND ME BEING
A PRO FOOTBALL PLAYER.
LIKE I WOULD BE A DISSERVICE
TO NOT GO HELP THAT KID OUT
LITTLE BIT.
NEED TO SERVICE. YOU HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO PULL OVER THE
CAR AND STARTED COACHING
UP SOME RANDOM KID
ON THE SIDE OF THE
THE ROAD,
NO CHOICE.
NOW. WE SAW JERRY JONES
PUT A LOT OF SALT ON HIS
MCGRIDDLE. I DON'T KNOW. WHAT
DO YOU PAIR WITH A MCGRIDDLE?
WHAT KIND OF WINE GOES WITH A
MCGRIDDLE? HE PUT SALT ON A
MCGRIDDLE,
A LOT OF SALT. YEAH. YOU
DIDN'T SEE THAT ON HARD
KNOCKS. WELL,
YA KNOW. I DIDN'T. I DID NOT
SEE THE
HARD KNOCKS. WOW.
WELL, HE PUTS A LOT OF SALT ON
IT. YOU NEED YOU NEED
SOMETHING THAT'S GOING TO
COMBAT. THAT SAW SOMETHING.
THAT'S,
YOU KNOW,
ACTUALLY, IT'S THE GREAT
THINGS.
SALT GOES WITH ANY KIND OF
WINE. REALLY,
IT WON'T MAKE ANY
STRANGE, IT LESS OR MORE.
SO NO, I DON'T
KNOW.
IT WAS KIND OF WEIRD.
BUT IT WAS, YOU KNOW, IT WAS
KIND OF A WEIRD MOMENT. LIKE I
SAID,
ANYTIME YOU'RE TURNING TO A
PANCAKE FOR SUPPORT YOU'VE
ALREADY LOST ITS SUPPORTING
THE REST OF THE SANDWICH. SO
WE'RE ALREADY IN A BAD
SITUATION
FIRED UP BECAUSE THAT'S THE
OWNER OF HIS FAVORITE FOOTBALL
TEAM, AND HE'S PUTTING SALT
NOW. CJ'S JUST THROW IN SEAS,
LIKE SALT BAY OVER THERE.
THEY'RE JUST THROWING SALT ON
EVERYTHING.
YOU THOUGHT THEY FEED HIM.
DID YOU EVER HAVE HARD KNOCKS
ON ONE OF YOUR
TEAM'S YOU EVER
HAVE. WERE YOU EVER IN A
HARD KNOCKS OVER THE YEARS?
IT WAS NOT A HARD KNOCKS AT
ALL. I WASN'T EVEN LIKE
PLAYING AGAINST A TEAM ON
HARD ENOUGH.
SELF-AWARENESS. THE GUYS KNOW
THEY'RE BEING FILMED SO YOU
CAN TELL, WHICH GUYS ARE KIND
OF PERFORMING AND PUTTING IT
ON OF ALL YOUR TEAMMATES.
SO WHO WOULD HAVE LOVED TO
HAVE BEEN ON
HARD KNOCKS YOU THINK?
PROBABLY
ALL THE ENOUGH. I THINK YOU
ONLY BE STILL THAT ARE HARRIS
THOUGH. HE WAS, HE WAS
PROBABLY ONE OF MY FUNNIEST
TEAMMATES OF ALL TIME.
HE WAS HILARIOUS. I THINK
TO BE ON HER KNOTS WHEN I WAS
IN WASHINGTON BECAUSE HE WAS A
MASSIVE HAM.
HE WAS I LOVED HIM. HE WAS SO
ANNOYING.
HE WAS
LOOK, I REMEMBER END MEETINGS,
LIFE, SAVER GUMMIES,
BUT FOR SOME REASON, HE WOULD
NOT, I THINK HE
DISCARDED. ALL THE RED ONES.
SO
WHEN I WOULD LIKE GO TO THE
BATHROOM AND COME BACK, I
WOULD LOOK ON MY IPAD AND SEE
A BUNCH OF RED
LIFESAVER GUMMIES.
I THOUGHT HE WAS THE STRANGEST
MAN IN THE WORLD.
I LOVE YOU SAID I LOVE
HIM. HE'S SO ANNOYING.
THAT TELLS ME THAT YOU GUYS
ARE REALLY CLOSE. I LOVE THAT.
THAT'S GREAT. YES.
APPRECIATE YOU SPENDING SOME
TIME.
WE'LL ENJOY THE SEASON AND
ENJOY
A NICE CABERNET FROM
PASO ROBLES CALLED ALEKSANDAR.
THAT'S FROM SASHA
VICH. I THINK YOU'LL FIND IT.
IT QUITE DELIGHTFUL CAUTIOUS.
YES, YOU KNOW
PASSABLE IS POPPING RIGHT NOW.
OBVIOUSLY, DOW IS HOLDING
IT DOWN AND
BOOKER BOOKER WINES IS REALLY
GOOD. BOOK OF VINEYARDS,
USE ME UP THERE AND OBVIOUSLY
EVERYONE WAS LIKE AWESOME
QUOTE. THAT'S LIKE
THEY'RE LIKE THE NEW ME O ME
OR SOMETHING LIKE THAT. I'M
SURE YOU'RE ALREADY ON THE
LIST, BUT YOU GOT TO GET ON
CARMELO'S WINE NEWSLETTER.
IT'S CALLED WHAT'S IN YOUR
GLASS, EVERY MONDAY GREAT
SELECTIONS ON PINOS FROM THE
WILLAMETTE VALLEY
CARMELO, DOING GREAT STUFF IN
THE
THE WINE GAME.
CARMELA IS LEGIT. THERE IS
NO
QUESTION ABOUT IT. SO I'M
SCARED TO HANG OUT WITH
CARMELA WHEN WE DO
YEAH. SEAMLESS OF THOSE
BOTTLES. HE'S POPPED WITH
JIMMY OVER IN FRANCE. THAT
THAT MIGHT BE LIKE HALF YOUR
NFL CAREER EARNINGS.
APPRECIATE YOU
BUT THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
THEY'RE SCARING EVERYBODY AWAY
WITH THOSE EXPENSIVE
AS WINES.
REALLY A MAN. CAN'T YOU CAN'T
YOU CAN'T BE SCARED AWAY FROM
GOTTA GET IN THERE OVER THE
PRICE POINT THAT SENSIBLE
WHICH IS WHY I THINK YOU'LL
ENJOY THE NEWSLETTER. WHAT'S
IN YOUR GLASS? EVERY MONDAY
FROM CARMELO, ANTHONY. THANKS
SO MUCH
WILL APPRECIATE YOU GUYS